[Music]
many years ago when i was a younger man
early 20s i would say i got to be i was
asked to be a correspondent for e news e
e e and i said yes and um they sent me
uh because it was a free trip anything
for a tr free anything i would do and it
was a free trip to monaco you still do
that yeah no i know i don't always use
the past tense and um
they sent me to monaco and i remember um
i interviewed
patrick duffy and i got to um meet i
think i interviewed him prince albert of
monaco royalty and i thought well how
are they letting me do this like how do
i have the cred i don't have any
credentials except an e-badge those are
credentials yeah i guess so but like
those are literally credentials i know
but not like professional credentials as
someone who had done that before and
he's like a royal a member of a royal
i know i think that now but at the time
i thought a prince and he looked like
just he was very nice he looked like
just like a normal he looked like a
suburban dad like he looked like a guy
like who would bring his kid to soccer
in the town we grew up a regular guy she
did i got news for you he is a regular
guy
albert i know but i know but royalty
it's so silly i know but at the time i
thought
i was
under that impression that like royalty
is special and like that i i subscribe
to that
ridiculous belief so what happened he
was just fine he was nice and like
whatever nothing much happened that's a
hell of a story here we go
if you like that you're gonna love the
show life could be a dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
you're listening to life is short i'm
your incredible storytelling host
[Music]
with me as always is christian long my
brother you have you have a better name
than i do
christian lying just justin not only is
it easier to say but it's less overtly
embarrassing also the name christian it
it just like notes too much notes
what's the difference i don't know i
feel like i don't know anything anymore
i'm pretty i'm pretty sure i'm getting
dumber as i get older well i think that
doesn't make sense your brain just
degrades
but that's why you gotta read and keep i
have been reading i have been reading
you know a great book to read is uh this
book called ten percent what is that
well it's uh actually written by our
guest today that was a quick pivot two
pivots and also the reason that we're
talking about
correspondence oh yeah you're a
correspondent
uh once and i i think i've already told
this but the other thing i remember
doing as a correspondent was um falling
in front of donald trump you have told
that yeah i will say that story the
prince albert story as stories go it was
a really good setup for a story yeah you
were in monaco working for e you were
interviewing prince albert and then
he was a nice guy
you know it was a really good start i
know that's such a fear of mine there's
a character who does that you're like
you're like del griffith
i know i know who tells these stories
like they're going to go somewhere yeah
uh and stephen you're steve martin
saying here's an idea next time you tell
a story try to have a point it makes it
so much more enjoyable for the listener
i'm sorry i got you derailed from your
really efficient
guest introduction and a double
introduction i found a way to use him as
a wreck because he's a writer he's a
correspondent kind of like me
um uh he
isn't i mean one of the
big huge correspondents war
correspondent fact for abc news uh he's
the author of a book that i love called
10 percent happier his name is dan
harris i believe he recently retired
from abc news yes he was i should have
used past tense also i no longer am a
correspondent for he i should have made
that clear steve kametco took took over
but once it corresponded always a
correspondent you know i guess so i
could always say that like eagle scouts
you know once you're an eagle scout
you're always an eagle scout yeah god i
mean what if you did something
embarrassing then you're like never
doing that again like would you say like
well once uh foot liquor or what once a
necrophiliac oh he's a necrophiliac you
went from foot liquor to nick
you know why because fucker's not fast
no i was like oh it's innocent
it can be foot licker it can be if
you're just horsing around i i've like
licked
just like innocently horsing around just
like playing around with your lover or
something like just being silly uh i
guess so i mean you'd probably have to
be your lover it wouldn't be you can't
do it to a stranger just lick their feet
that'd be dangerous yes so dan harris
right right see dana harris doesn't get
derailed this way
well he's a professional he's a
professional and but al he did have uh a
moment that we're going to talk about
like a really intense episode where he
was reading a teleprompter on the news
and he had a panic attack he had an
anxiety attack that he then
started investigating and the causes of
it and how to fix it really and that was
kind of the impetus for his whole this
whole new career that he has now as um
a meditation specialist someone who
created an app wrote a book about it and
he's been very forthcoming about his
experience with uh mental health and
anxiety and so you should create an app
right oh yeah yeah i knew i knew you're
gonna say i knew what what you were
saying but it sounded a little bit like
he created an app oh i did i don't know
it just sounded mumbling so he wouldn't
do that either i wanted it to be clear
because it's important it is an app an
app an app he created an app and uh he
has really good diction
anyway um
but you've been really inspired by him
you've been doing this app right and you
have um
you speak very highly of not only him
but of meditation in general yes other
meditation specialists on it i really
love anushka um joseph goldstein there's
great people who i'm specialists who
lead these meditations these daily
meditations and yeah it really has
helped me i if you listen to the show if
you listen to more than one episode you
know
you know how i feel about it if you know
you know yeah i talk about it probably
too often so here we go let's just get
into it and begin
and hear from the man himself the dan
the man
that's uh did you play on that no i
didn't plan saying dan the man
uh do you stay on that
okay stan i'm trying to talk like the
millennials um anyway this oh my god i
just got picked pitched a commercial to
do where basically i'm like the old
stuffy guy that's that's what the whole
point of the commercial is it's like
it's like a millennial comes out and
it's like hey old man like this is the
cool way to do it sad i know but you
know what you should meditate about it
i'm going to and embrace that the time
moving forward and live in the present
be mindful and that's what we're gonna
talk today about with uh dan harris
someone who has really changed my life
and someone uh whom i am always going to
be grateful for so here he is
you'll hear me let him know that uh
several times probably uh because it
really is true and i appreciate him
coming on and talking about it come on
all right here he is dan
life harris be a dream sweetheart
hello
[Music]
forgive me if i'm gonna be overly
familiar with you because you've been
such a big part of my life i see you
every day
so this is not at all unusual for me
it's a little surreal
i you talk to me a lot but i never get
to talk to you
that's really cool i appreciate hearing
that thank you what does your shirt say
well so this is wicked smart yeah this
is all our massachusetts guests i like
to wear it
where are you
i'm from newton yeah oh okay i shouldn't
say this but it's in my head now and i
and i won't be able to get around it i
lost my virginity to a girl from newton
i don't know how else to say that
if that doesn't make it in the show i'm
going to be very upset it should i i
feel like i've said it before
on the show i promise you it'll be in
there and she knows and i'm not going to
say her name
but she knows who she is
i hope she's listening
[Laughter]
newton mass what a nice um just a nice
suburban
hamlet right yeah um it's actually uh
technically it is a city so it has a
bunch of hamlets within it but it's got
quite a bit of economic diversity so
it's got like sumner redstone lives
there but oh wow a lot of housing
projects that's who i lost my virginity
to sam to redstone yeah
is he a generous lover oh he was really
gentle yeah he was i probably shouldn't
have said that um
uh now i feel like i've diminished
newton uh i'm
sorry to any listener also is this dude
are do people have the accent there i
mean is it is it a strong accent oh yeah
i i just spent a couple days up in maine
with my son and oh sure i was doing a
boston accent the whole time it is very
strong and the main is similar right but
a little bit i remember them sort of
saying coming up at the end do they come
up at the end
yes they do it's it's a thicker
it's a thicker slower accent i cannot do
a main accent even though i lived there
for eight years oh wow uh but i can do i
can do sort of like a version of a
boston accent and but you start you
probably had to wean yourself off of it
i mean as a as a journalist as an on-air
anchor
you probably they probably stress a more
neutral sound i would imagine you know i
never really had it to be honest because
my dad's from jersey and my mother was a
sort of like upper crusty bostonian new
upper uh north shore new englander and
uh she didn't really have a thick accent
either um so i didn't have to wean
myself i had many other changes i had to
make in order to be acceptable in public
but uh not that what was the top the
biggest one was it your
was the way you dress was the way you
presented yourself well my mentor when i
was new at abc news was this guy peter
jennings and he used to constantly
torment me for having horrible fashion
well
yeah i grew up i peter jennings to me
was like the epitome of what it meant to
be
a a man like a solid
you know authoritative uh person he was
so impressive and i read your book i
love this book ten percent happier um
and you go into some
uh really hilarious detail about
that dinette the dynamic that you had
with him and and um
how respected but also how feared he was
as a boss as just as a boss i never
thought of him that way i just as he was
on my tv he delivered the news um
what was that experience like if you can
distill it uh and the detail is so great
in the book but what was it like to work
with him complex complex character i
loved peter i idolized him my whole like
though for my whole life yeah i i met
him and still when i met him and he saw
the many aspects of his personality i
still idolized him he was so smart so
brave so smooth so are pain um i loved
him and he changed my life he you know i
was this
schlubby
very youthful looking kind of plankton
who came up from local news arrived at
abc news when i was 28 didn't know
anything and he sent me all over the
world man and i it changed my life and
he is
was
really cranky and could be pretty mean
and i sometimes described it to i think
i described it in the book as being
thrilling in the way putting your head
into a tiger's mouth is thrilling you
know not safe
yeah so being in his orbit you know he
would just say things to you that we're
complete really cutting or like remember
one day i walked downstairs to his
office with i was wearing this plaid
jacket which was
yeah in hindsight it was a very ugly
jacket but he looked at me as like oh
yeah you're going to wear that on
television
um and he's just that that was just
really tricky he was canadian too right
so he probably had a really dry delivery
yes um he another time i was standing in
iraq
130 degrees probably no probably 120
degrees honestly in baghdad after the
war you know the war had just ended but
the insurgency was about to begin and i
was doing a live shot and he got in my
ear right before the show started it was
like i really think you need to be
you know wearing suit and tie
oh no and i was like dude
first of all why are you commenting at
this before i'm doing a live shot and i
haven't slept you know and second
you know how hot it is
so that was the kind of thing he would
do was it to throw you off course do you
think it was deliberate was it or was it
purely it was in his head
and um
and and he
he needed to say it or was was there any
kind of do you think uh
subconscious
motives for it
i think that
yes to all of it i i think the more i
learned about the way my mind works and
i think the way
the mind generally works is that there
are there are often many
levels of
contributing motivations to any given
action and so with peter i think on the
benign end of the spectrum he really you
know he wanted to take care of me he
wanted to see me succeed on the other
hand i think he also wanted to see if i
could take a fastball um right and i
think he had a tortured relationship
with some of his own mentors and and so
maybe didn't learn the best uh you know
interpersonal hygiene who do you think
peter jennings mentors what would it be
like walter cronkite and edward armor
like the the heavies that you would
imagine
i was watching last night actually with
my wife uh a documentary that i found to
be really triggering fascinating but
very triggering for me
it's called uh mike wallace is here and
it's about the the great 60 minutes
newsman mike wallace it's available
the documentary on hulu um
and i'm not just saying that because i
work for disney and disney owns hulu
it's i would have no matter where it was
available i would recommend it and um
uh it was
eye-opening because you just it just
reminded me how this older generation of
news mostly men so new men and a few
women they were really mean to each
other it went hyper competitive and
roone arledge who was the president of
abc news
um
developed a star system so we had peter
jennings
uh hugh downs barbara walters diane
sawyer ted koppel david brinkley and
they and they pitted one them against
each other and so he was when i got to
abc news
it was a it was a really hostile place
and if you were friends with peter if he
was considered one of peter's boys then
the other anchors might not like you oh
my god really tough yeah you you
described that in the book again very
hilariously um
and that was a surprise to me that uh it
happens the competitive uh this happens
within the ranks of that network i would
have thought it was you know you compete
with cbs or cnn whatever but you and
david wright uh you said you had a
you're so honest in this book too about
you know some of these
less attractive moments um which i i
i always find really inspiring um and
that's what led you to what we'll talk
about which is your um
focus on meditation but uh how quickly
did did you
recognize that environment how quickly
did that become apparent that it was
this cutthroat competitive
uh
atmosphere
very quickly even as i was doing
interviews for the job one of the
executives sat me down and said
yeah they were they were auditioning me
to be to anchor this sort of fun
overnight show that they have that was
at the time anchored by a guy named
anderson cooper yeah and i remember this
executive sat me down i was like yeah i
could see you doing this but i could
never see you being a correspondent like
a real journalist
that was just the type of [ __ ] that came
out of people's mouths all the time how
do you respond to something like that
how did i respond yeah yeah i was
thinking right
i was so desperate to have the job that
i just said yeah okay fine i i think i
probably agreed with him you know i was
so young what did i know yeah oh yeah
i'm the worst
yeah you kind of have to just take it i
guess
i remember another time one of the
executives i i gotten sick like deathly
ill
when i was covering
you remember howard dean ran for
president in 2004
yes yes the night of his scream oh i i
got a flu and i had to stay in iowa for
like a week and i had to go to the
hospital i was really sick and i got
back to the new to the to this to the
main headquarters in new york and one of
the my boss said
you know getting sick like that bad luck
for you
oh wow yeah wow any sort of weakness yep
oh my god that's terrifying so that's
the high pressure environment that
you're in and that's kind of like the
jumping off point for
your book i just want to talk about the
pressure a little bit more and um
i found all of this so fascinating when
you went overseas you became a war
correspondent and
which must have been a dream what did
that feel like to get to go over there
and what kind of fear did that instill
in you it was way more thrilling than i
thought uh-huh
i had no and i never crossed my mind
even as i was working my way up through
local news stations and i got to abc
news i never really had any ambition to
be a combat reporter i i really at all i
just hadn't really thought about it and
then 911 happened and i immediately
wanted to go overseas to cover whatever
was going to happen next and i think
there were a couple motivations one was
um
idealism you know i think it's important
to have people like at the tip of the
spear witnessing what what the
government is doing in our name
i think the other reason was curiosity
just like whoa what's that gonna be like
and then the third was ambition raw
ambition really wanting to move up in my
chosen fields what i did not foresee was
that in these environments where you are
really at risk
uh you're being shot at and their bombs
going off that it's exciting i wouldn't
do it now that i have a little you know
i'm 50 and i've had a little kid and i i
would not never do it now but in my
early 30s it was totally thrilling and
that is a drug that's what you yeah that
was interesting too and your mother
there's a great quote i think it's from
your mother about the ego aspect of it
about um the idea of just being a fame
and and being successful in that and i
forget exactly what she says but it's i
had this off my mom is uh
incredibly brilliant woman who was uh a
pioneering academic physician at harvard
and just quite an intimidating presence
and somebody i really look up to and
respect and i remember her saying
something offhand
in my youth at some unspecified point in
my youth that anybody who would run for
president or want to be famous must have
some unfillable
hole at the core of their being and that
was on my mind sometimes when i realized
that i really wanted to be a famous
journalist like what's wrong with me i
bet well i that's again you're so honest
about that and i i'm sure it's something
that everyone i think that about
politicians as well there is uh you
can't get away from that that there is
this
there is an ego aspect to it uh wanting
to be seen and want you talk about
people on the jumbotron at a baseball
game how excited they get
um and how that most people have a
little bit of that in them and i never
thought of
journalists or you know correspondence
as having that but it makes sense that
they would
scale the scale the dopamine hit that
you get from showing up on the jumbotron
or having people like your instagram
post right scale that to infinity and
that's what it's like to be on the
television on the regular especially in
a war zone you know
and to have peter jennings saying our
man in afghanistan yes that you're that
man you're the guy on the
was it um
did that kind of um overwhelm any of the
fear in terms of getting you talked
about getting shot at uh which is
something that very few people have
experienced um
did was what was that what was that like
that it did it did overwhelm the fear in
many cases you know it's like um i think
i use this example but i don't know if
you ever notice there's a difference
between your experience of a thing when
you're filming it with your iphone then
when you're actually just there totally
totally yeah so when you're covering
news like that and you're just driven by
getting the story and doing a good job
i found that i wasn't as worried about
normal
sane things to worry about like am i
going to die today i mean yes i did have
those concerns and i didn't have a death
wish or anything like that but i was so
motivated by the other things the
idealism the curiosity the ambition
the thrill of it that i often really
didn't
i i didn't i didn't get scared much and
i say this as a died in the wool
scaredy cat you know i've had anxiety my
whole life i had to go to shrink when i
was a little kid because i was so
worried about nuclear war so i i had no
previous track record of bravery uh but
for in this case i was i i wasn't
terrified all the time and and you even
when you first got the assignment so you
you talk about this um you talk about
you're telling your father and the
reaction that he had which i thought was
really
i think probably typical of someone who
cares about their son he he cried he was
scared did that did a reaction like that
give you pause or were you so
eager to go that it was again it was
just kind of your ambition drove you
it did give me pause and man if my son
ever did to me what i did not to my
parents i would be distraught it did
give me pause when i called him to tell
him i was going in it was the first time
i was going into a war zone i was in
pakistan but i got an opportunity to
embed with the taliban who were then in
control
uh uh uh now uh also in control um god
what is right before they fell sorry
what are you gonna say sorry dan i i
what what is that like to know that i
mean this is you're talking about an
event 20 years ago yeah and now of
course we we know that they're they've
ceased power again how does that just
somebody who's personally involved in
that story but how does that feel to see
that happen again it's sad and scary you
know it's definitely i'm just scared for
i mean these were they they were not
responsible leaders to say the least
yeah and you know who knows what they're
going to do now it's terrifying for all
the people in afghanistan and the
foreign the wisdom of the foreign policy
move and all that other stuff i'll i'll
leave to people who are more nuanced
thinkers than me but just the the raw fa
brute facts of the situation for people
who live there that just sucks it does
and and
something you said struck me about the
the ki their kids who are fighting that
war kids on both sides but um you talked
about some of the taliban that you were
embedded with uh as just being
kids they were curious they were
teaching you swear words yes they were
there was a lightheartedness to them
that i thought was really
interesting um that how much did that
shape the way you saw
that country the the people there and
and
what was happening to them you know
having had the opportunity to travel all
over the world yeah in heightened
situations
how normal things often are i mean you
still have to eat you still have to go
to the bathroom you still
you know these people still make jokes
you still gossip you're so curious about
other yeah exactly and so yeah the
taliban
they look
fearsome in still photos yeah um but if
you're hanging around with them many of
them are just young kids with no other
opportunity who were just doing this
thing because that's what their dad did
or whatever um
no i i probably the higher you go i
didn't hang out with mullah omar i'm
sure he was genuinely terrified he
probably wasn't a big laugh no no and i
definitely wouldn't be sharing bar
mitzvah stories
that's right
oh my god my aunt got me the weirdest
thing
uh
yeah
yeah i but but it must have been um to
have lived in america too i've never
seen anything like that i'm just so
fascinated by that experience what that
must have been like just to get shot at
i mean just the just the idea of being
you you talk about you describe it as
like a whistling noise just the noise of
it the sounds the
the feel um
when were you scared when were you like
oh [ __ ] this could this could be like a
death situation definitely i mean there
were absolutely i don't want to portray
that that in moments where you hear
whistling overhead of a bullet going
over that i didn't have fear i
absolutely did have fear and uh there
were moments i remember being in so
after i covered afghanistan there was a
second intifada in israel palestine and
i spent a i spent quite a bit of time in
a city called ramallah which is where
the headquarters of the plo
is or was and uh the israelis invaded
and i was
some bunch of journalists we were all
holed up in this house together and
there was a very experienced uh war
correspondent who was with us and i
remember she had an eye patch because
her eye had been
um knocked out uh in sri lanka her name
was marie cold and uh there was actually
a movie made about her not long ago and
i remember her running into the room and
because they were shelling buildings on
our block and i remember her running
into the room and saying this is bad and
there are plenty of moments where i was
really scared or i remember driving a
car through ramallah at one point and i
saw an israeli tank and the turrets
started slowly turning toward us oh my
and so absolutely i am not immune to
that at all but i think you over
or you know what did winston churchill
say or he's purported to have said that
there's nothing more thrilling than the
bullet that misses you and so you once
the bullet misses you're like you know i
write about this my my first thought is
are we rolling on this like this is good
stuff yeah that's a badge of honor
and yeah and and you your fellow
correspondents joke about how when you
go back to america you're going to be
celebrated or you're going to be you
know at least using it at bars to um
to boost your social standing i'm still
dining out on this [ __ ] like you're
impressed and like yeah so i get to talk
about this it's working i'm 50 years old
this hap this stuff happened many many
years ago i still get to get the so yes
there if you want to stay on the and i'm
always happy to do this because i love
talking about the whole catastrophe of
the human mind like the crass side of of
this is real it is absolutely real
[Music]
in an effort to balance my sleeping
schedule which is the older i get it's
become that much more important for me
to get a good night's sleep i've been
doing it with plus cbd it's been the
best it's been really like my go-to
product for adjusting my sleep schedule
and getting like a really good full
night of sleep if you are in a similar
boat you might want to check out plus
cbd it's formulated by a team of medical
experts and doctors so it's not just
some i know there are a lot of products
out there now but they actually work
with experts people who know what
they're doing they taste great the
gummies taste great and they're made
with award-winning cbd it's combined
with melatonin magnolia bark and lemon
balm we've tried three different kinds
of gummies the the calm gummies which
are great during the day if you need a
little relapse yeah that's right you can
do it during the day the sleep gummies
and if you're feeling a little cheeky a
little cheeky
there's the
there's the reserve collection which in
addition to the cbd has 2.5 milligrams
of thc
they're fun and if you're not uh if you
don't have a lot of experience but
you've been curious about thc and it's a
nice dosage to start with it's very mild
mild but it's still fun so you still
feel it it's a giggly fun uh time right
before you you get a nice night of sleep
visit pluscbdoil.com and enter promo
code long for 40 off your order you
won't regret it oh man i've been
traveling
my favorite new way to travel is by
putting on my sweats my fiori sweatpants
on the plane it's so nice you like you
just get to a little break i wear the
viewers everywhere yeah i always think
you're going to the gym you're wearing
them now well you went to the gym today
and you did other things like leisurely
things i did it all you did it all and
you did it all in your fiori i sure did
i'm looking at them i'm a perfect i'm a
walking example of how great this
product is it's funny every time i saw
you in viori's before this because you
recently started going to the gym you
had not to shame you you hadn't been
going to the gym for a long time but i'd
see you in your fiores and and assume
that you were going to the gym i i like
giving off that assumption yeah but now
you're actually doing it i am and you
can i mean you just we have a meeting
coming up i assume you're not going to
change no way
because they look great they look great
no matter what you're doing
they're built to move and sweat and yes
but they also have a cool look they
break down the boundaries of traditional
activewear so
i would say they're a new perspective on
performance apparel
yeah that's safe to say well their
mission is to create quality products
without extra waste that we should have
led with this they offset a hundred
percent of their carbon footprint so you
can wear it you can feel good about
wearing them get twenty percent off your
first purchase at viori.com
long that's viori which is spelled
v-u-o-r-i
dot com slash long and you get 20 off
again good gift
[Music]
you've had all these um traumatic
experiences that you were not really
dealing with then right you you come
back to america and then
what was the next what what
followed that and what led you then to
uh what you're doing now so after three
or four years of covering wars in
afghanistan and israel palestine and
then also in um iraq and iraq was really
where i
made my bones i spent a lot of time
there um
months and months and months
i came home in the summer of 2003 after
a five or six month long
sojourn in iraq which spanned the
pre-invasion invasion and then
much of the beginnings of the insurgency
and that was just the first time i went
but i came home that summer and i
started to get depressed although i
didn't know i was depressed and i
so i was really feeling low-key and
tired and
run down
sort of sort of fluish
for months and um
i
had all these
tests done and i would make my parents
were both physicians i would make them
try to help me figure out what was going
on and uh
one night in the middle of this period a
friend of mine
offered me some cocaine
uh which i i was 32 or three i'd never
done any hard drugs and i don't know why
i just said yes
and it made me feel better this is not a
recommendation
by the way
we'll be right back yeah exactly they
are one of our sponsors right so
if you could not talk about the negative
effects that'd be great
yeah but no i love the way you describe
it's also like you're such a
you're such a great writer so eloquent
that like just that the feeling that the
drip i think you call like an
ammonium
taste the uh the ammonia taste that's
the drip and then 15 seconds later uh
you know it kicks in and
just as that shot of serotonin um but
then you talk about the depletion
afterwards the next day which is my
friend calls the the blues
you you talk about how you blew with
blues very hard
yeah there's no free lunch if you want
to synthetically squirt you know all
these
happy chemicals into your brain that
this there's going to be a
yeah at least for me there were
consequences and they were deeply
unpleasant yeah yeah and um would you
say it was worse on because you talked
about doing ecstasy
uh mdma and stuff was that was that
worse does that deplete your serotonin
even more for me for me it was worse
yeah you just feel
awful and depleted and sad and and
yeah that's what led to the panic attack
it was an honor panic attack i i had
never i hadn't seen it until um i read
your book and um
can you describe to people what exactly
happened i'm sure you're sick of talking
about this but it really is so
interesting and it's led you to all of
this great work i'm happy to talk about
it there's another story i've been
dining out on for a long time i'm happy
to tell it uh the video it's a classic
it's a cloud it's a chest yeah um if you
if you look at the you the video many
people's response to the video which if
you just
type panic attack on television it's i
believe the first response which is
great for me
did you ever think you'd be encouraging
people to watch it no no i mean i was
so ashamed after it after it happened so
ashamed it was like the most
embarrassing thing that ever happened to
me
um and that includes like wetting my bed
as an 11 year old summer camp which i
which i you know like had to like burn
the sheets
we're going to talk about that next
that's my that was my next week put that
down let's get it all out here now um
i'll send you
you can send me a bill afterwards for
the therapy uh so yeah i i uh
i was filling in as the
news reader on good morning america so
the news reader is the person who comes
on at the top of each hour to reason
read a few headlines we don't have this
job anymore but back then it was done by
robin roberts who's now the main host of
the show
robin was off that morning so i was
filling in for her i had done it many
times before so i wasn't nervous per se
going into the gig and i hadn't been
high recently so i had no reason to
foresee what was about to happen which
was that i a few seconds into my shtick
i think i was supposed to read six or
seven short stories off the teleprompter
a few seconds after saying good morning
i just i don't know what happened first
either my mind started to say dude
you're nervous or my body's just started
to react in some way but my heart
started raising my lungs seized up my
palms were sweating my mouth dried up
and then my mind started freaking out
because of the body being in mutiny mode
and that made the body worse and that
made the mind worse and i tried to
soldier through it
but you can see if you watch the video
i'm like having trouble breathing my
face has gone pale despite the makeup um
my you can hear my like throat is
constricted and i'm kind of gulping a
little bit and a few seconds into it i
just i just throw it back to the main
hosts of the show diane sawyer and
charlie gibson say you know back to you
guys i quit basically in the middle and
if i had if i hadn't had the opportunity
to do that then it would have been a
total disaster i would have had to rip
the mic off and run away because it was
i felt so horrible that would have been
the next step is just to hell with it
and running away weeping i don't know
what else is up
maybe you [ __ ] yourself maybe yes
maybe you defecate um i love how you
call charles gibson avuncular that's
such a great word for charles gibson um
he is a fun killer uh but of all people
to like have that happen in front of
like forget the millions of people
because sometimes i think like
okay that's that's all conceptual you
know that the millions of people you
can't see millions of people watching
but like diane sawyer yeah
charles gibson to do that in front of
that so what did they think were they
like
does he having a stroke uh
what did did they have any idea what had
happened
charlie i remember ran out of his seat
and ran over to make sure i was okay and
like
all this yeah he's yeah and diane was
worried they were all really worried i
lied and told them
i knew what had happened you said it was
a bit i yeah i said it was a bit like
yeah you guys did that joke land or what
oh busted
i'm just kidding
i mean i was i was just really desperate
to get out of it but i knew what had
happened i remember i went backstage and
my mom called me it was like you just
had a panic attack and oh wow then i
went to go see a shrink and that really
kind of made things better you had to
admit to the shrink that you were doing
drugs yeah that shrink asked me a bunch
of questions to try to figure out what
had gone wrong i knew i had a panic
attack i didn't know the drugs that
caused it and he asked you know do you
do drugs and i said yes and then he kind
of gave me this look that signaled uh
okay [ __ ] mystery solved and it's
ding-ding-ding
yeah and so i i
you know he i very much encouraged me to
quit doing drugs i did immediately that
day
and he said you know you got to come see
me once or twice a week and definitely
he didn't think i needed to go to rehab
at least not yet he wanted to monitor me
and i was able to stay off of it because
it was the stakes were so high i didn't
want to ruin my career of course yeah is
it something you missed dan is that's do
you ever have moments where you're like
oh man 100 absolutely yeah way less
because this was a long time ago now of
2004 so it's not like i'm walking around
craving cocaine but in those first years
i missed it all the time
because i loved doing drugs frankly and
because so many of my close friends you
know i had had all these bonding
experiences with people and they were
still doing it and it sort of i couldn't
hang around with them and so it was
really complex now that i'm old and all
my friends are old like it's not that
big of a deal um yeah but sure yeah i
mean like there's
there's a reason why these drugs become
so popular they do things to the brain
that make you feel good yeah yeah that's
true was did something replace that
would you say meditation replace that or
is that too
simple a
diagnosis
oh meditation is amazing and i will i
will rhapsodize about it but it's it's
nowhere near as fun on the short term
basis as cocaine so it's not i i
i think there's a there were some
addictive things that kicked in the sort
of like compulsive need to master it
yeah to learn more
and then to like become successful at
writing a book and then launching a
podcast and an app and all that other
stuff i think the addictive stuff is
around that i see i will say that
there's one aspect of meditation that i
have struggled with as i've become more
experienced which is that concentrating
the mind focusing the mind can for some
meditators create some very pleasant
bodily sensations there's a technical
term for this
p-i-t-i-p-t it's an ancient word uh i
think that roughly translates into the
rapture
and
in my later years as a meditator
recently uh in the last three or four
years
as i've gotten better i don't know if
that's even the right word but as i've
gotten more experience at it yeah there
are many times where i sit to meditate
and it feels very good and it's kind of
a sort of a less synthetic cousin to
mdma
and
i was having a conversation with my
meditation teacher recently who was
basically kind of doing his gentle
finger wagging at me
is that just joseph goldstein yeah i
write a lot about in my book i love him
he's incredible and he's very very funny
and i was on retreat with him a couple
months ago he's like damn you got to get
you got to move past the rapture you're
like stuck in this and so i can see my
addictive stuff coming around
oh wow you're so lucky you get to
be mentored by him he's i love him um
he's got such a calming voice too a lot
of i love
all of the the um meditation specialists
on the app but so what was the thing
that led you to meditation what was the
ultimate thing that um
that got you there wait hold on a second
i want to i do want to can you say more
because i'd just be curious not
necessarily about the app or anything
like that but just your experience
how much meditation are you doing and
where where what's the tip of the spear
what's the moment when you really say oh
that now i get it it's working you know
what it is it was um whenever i would be
i would be triggered by certain things
whether it was uh
somebody cutting me off in traffic or
something uh my mother said that kind of
cut deep or um and i i would tend to be
very reactive
you know ever since i was little i would
be
i would react and um i think what it's
helped the most with is uh that
reactivity i think it's uh it's allowed
me to kind of check in with my breathing
and um process
these
let the emotions go through me they
sound like small moments you know but
but in terms of my psychological uh
journey my psychological life there
it's had huge a huge impact as an actor
i feel
it's it's helped me be a lot more
present in a scene
and there's such simple things but
there's things that i i
i think desperately needed
i was meditating just now and a fly kept
landing on me what do you do when that
happens i i meant to ask you that i have
this annoying horse fly
and i could hear 7a's voice in my head
okay breathe and you know in and out and
and i
i couldn't avoid the thought of the fly
i guess joseph would say make a mental
note of it uh a fly make a mental note
of fly on my arm or whatever
so yeah i would say that's it's it's
really
helped me remain present and mindful
which has been huge it's had huge
effects in my life i love hearing that
and i i
you're actually absolutely right that
that
to the uninitiated you know not losing
your temper while driving or not
snapping at your mom because she said
something to you
may sound small but that compounds and
by the way it doesn't mean you're going
to be perfect at it 10 is is pretty good
but but
reducing the amount of time that you
spend caught
in useless anger or rumination or fear
is a massive change really to the way we
live and um and the good news
among many pieces of good news is that
you can you just get better and better
at it this is a skill and that's what
you're doing every time you sit down
you're getting better and better at
working with your own mind i i am
curious how you came to how you came to
it after i had the panic attack i was
dealing with it through therapy right
but it kind of set me off on this
long and weird windy journey
that ultimately landed me on meditation
and the
probably one of the key moments in there
was that a friend of mine a colleague of
mine recommended that i read a book by a
guy named eckhart tolle who is a
diminutive elfin german um uh spiritual
teacher who's written many many
best-selling books yeah power of now he
is diminutive he's elfin
so i his book like
it was very very weird uh the book i was
reading and i went on to read several
books they're very strange and written
in this kind of syrupy spirit new age
language that i did not like uh but he
in the book gave this incredibly
compelling to me description of the
human condition he talks about how we
all have this ego or this voice in our
heads
which is
you know just serving up terrible ideas
on the regular and we because we're
unaware of this non-stop conversation
we're having with ourselves we just
we're owned by it you know so we're
constantly like checking our email in
the middle of a conversation with
somebody else or we're putting our hand
in the fridge we're not hungry or we're
losing our temper when it doesn't make
any sense which probably sounds familiar
to you and
and
that was a huge revelation to me i
realized oh okay this describes my inner
experience and it explains my panic
attack the voice in my head my ego
that's why i went off to wars without
thinking about it yeah came home got
depressed was insufficiently self-aware
to know that that was what was going on
blindly self-medicated with recreational
drugs and then just freaked out in front
of 5 million people
and
that was incredibly that was a huge
revelation to me
my hair was on fire
about this i went and interviewed him
i found him to be incredibly frustrating
because he's
i don't think he's full of [ __ ] by the
way i mean i've interviewed lots of
snake oil sales men and women and i do
not think eckhart tolle is one of those
people i i but he's got a sort of
otherworldly
diffidence and otherworldly
remove that i and and and he makes these
claims about how he's imperturbable that
i just couldn't really it's not that i
didn't believe him but like i didn't
know how that was uh relevant to my life
in any way and he also didn't say
anything that could help me get what he
has is it sort of performative dan no i
don't think so i really don't think so
and i am as skeptical as yeah
and i did my [ __ ] meter did not go
off with him
well his writing is so compelling i mean
like you said i mean it really was
compelling to you so
uh
what did you expect i mean what what did
you expect his personality to be
i wanted him to say
my first question was what do you do
about the voice in your head you're so
right about this yeah he said
take one conscious breath and i the
voice in my head was like what the [ __ ]
does that mean like what what am i what
does that even mean i'm glad the voice
in your head didn't come out through
your mouth no it didn't but i think my
face
which is not i'm not uh i wasn't able to
hide what i was thinking of a good poker
face
uh i was i was you know asking him this
question over and over and over again he
didn't give me an answer
that made any sense i understood the
words he was using but not in the order
in which he was using them and
you know i i um a friend of mine has
described eckhart tolle as
correct
but not useful
and interesting it was it it was after
meeting him that i then
started looking around for somebody who
could say something more practical and
then my oh sorry go ahead so well it
must be frustrating so it's like it's
like he has a diagno he's able to
diagnose it but there's no prescription
like you you're desperately trying to
get some sort of prescription from him
and and there's just uh
it's just kind of nonsense not nonsense
but it's not um useful
didn't didn't make any sense to me yeah
you know look the guy's got millions of
followers so i mean he he's doing
something right i think he's helping a
lot of people i am i am i don't i make
fun of him gently but i don't i don't
think he's a force for ill or anything
like that yeah yeah i didn't it didn't
make any sense to me so i i was i was at
wit's end and left to sort of look
around
huh so but that stuff i mean that's
those are the seeds certainly of um
of 10 i mean the voice in your head i i
love
when i get a meditation and they talk
about um
uh it's that it's a story anytime you
any fear that you have it's just a story
yes uh that you're telling yourself that
was always that was very useful to me
that was incredibly helpful um
being present and the idea that the
future hasn't happened uh so
you you you're wrestling with these
these things um and and you can see it
the benefits of them
but it's some it's a matter of accessing
them putting them into practice
it was a matter of uh yes exactly right
i mean i unders
i was super compelled by this idea of
this voice and ah in the head this
obnoxious inner dialogue yeah that this
nattering and yammering all the time but
i didn't know
what to do and then ultimately after
having spent a little time in the darker
precincts of the self-help world which
which was which was frustrating even
more frustrating and dispiriting my wife
or then fiance and now
baby mama and wife bianca
gave me a book by a
guy named dr mark epstein who's a shrink
who lives and works in manhattan
and has written a series of incredible
books
describing the overlap between freudian
psychology and buddhism and i did not
know anything about buddhism
but i was very intrigued by what i read
because it was clear to me that the
buddha 2600 years before totally started
cash in his royalty checks it was the
buddha who was talking about the voice
in the head he called it the monkey mind
and and
that we have this mind that is
constantly racing
random thoughts um
grasping onto things that will not last
in a universe that's characterized by
impermanence and entropy
lurching from one hit of pleasant
experience one slice of cake one latte
one vacation one promotion one hook up
to the next without ever being fully
sated
and
i just thought okay this is so smart and
the buddha had
something to do about it which was
meditation
of course
yeah and was that direct
it would then so that was the thing that
was the thing i read this book by dr
mark epstein what was the book dan sorry
the book was called going to pieces
without falling apart
okay i called him up and i said will you
have drinks with me and he said sure and
we went out for a couple beers and
uh he was so normal and so fallible you
know so open about his own flaws didn't
present himself as
you know some perfected guy he's just
you know is a
you know a dad and uh yeah
psych and an author and a
a successful psychiatrist and i was like
convinced and and shortly thereafter i
started to meditate and i think the big
piece of it also was that i i looked
around and saw that there was a lot of
scientific evidence that strongly
suggests that meditation is good for you
and that was what really put me over the
edge well and you also said specifically
that there is now new research being
done for um in terms of war
correspondence people who had been in
your position and the and the ptsd that
they were suffering yeah
how quickly did you realize that this
was something that
that
was beneficial to you
immediately now i had to get over my
skepticism because i oh you know
meditation i thought was you know for
hippies and weirdos and people who live
in a yurt and are really into you know
john tesh um yes so they can still do it
well you know what uh it's sadly that
isn't that is not a false stereotype
like there are a lot of people like that
um
but seeing the science
really was compelling how it could
rewire key parts of your brain lower
your blood pressure boost your immune
system it's really good for anxiety and
depression seeing that science is really
what got me compelled and then the first
time i meditated which i was at i was at
a beach house with my wife and some
friends and i sneaked away to a bedroom
i was in the middle of reading a book by
the pool and i went to one of the
bedrooms and i was like all right i'm
just going to try this set an alarm on
my blackberry because that was this was
a while ago at for five minutes and i
let rip and you know meditation is not
complicated it's you know beginning
mindfulness meditation is you know sit
quietly
focus your full attention on your breath
coming in and going out
and then every time you get distracted
which will happen a million times you
just start again and again and again and
a lot of people think when they get
distracted that uh
failed meditators yes i can't do this
but actually
seeing that you're distracted is proof
that you are meditating correctly
because the goal here is to create the
kind of self-awareness otherwise known
as mindfulness that allows you not to be
owned by the voice in your head and
i actually kind of understood that going
in so i wasn't discouraged by how
distractible i was i knew okay this is
like a bicep curl from my brain and i
had seen the brain scans and i just i
the first time i did it i was horrible
at it and it was humiliating
but i knew what sense
and what did i say what you what you do
what you see when you meditate is what
your life is actually about you might
think oh i'm justin long my my life is
all about um being the best podcaster
possible and and and
playing roles on on in film and
television and moving people and that is
true you that your life is about that it
is also from a moment-to-moment basis do
i need a haircut where do gerbils run
wild what's for lunch why did this
person get that role that i wanted why
did so and so not call me back and why
is so-and-so ghosting me on text and why
didn't i get more likes on this
instagram post it's mostly just gerbils
the gerbil yes as well yes right running
wild that i'm gonna that's
uh i'll pau i'll hold on that i'll table
that
is that there's gotta be truth to that
right we can cut this out but there's
got to be truth to that urban legend the
gerbil thing yeah i mean my wife
worked
during her medical training in um
in an emergency she had a rotation in
the emergency department and saw lots of
crazy crazy things right i've heard that
from friends i have not heard any
small varmint stories but the best story
that she told me was one day somebody
came in
he had somehow was a homeless person who
had somehow gotten his hands on a
prescription pad and he handed in a
prescription
uh
he in the letters were m-o-f-e-e-n
mophene
one pound
take as directed
that's
amazing take as directed is the best
part
that's amazing
yeah
did they fill i hope they filled it it
is a prescription pad
uh that's incredible but yes i know all
of the
uh all of the noise in the head all of
the stories that
um that you tell yourself i guess um
i do want to know uh about
how this has affected you
your day to day how has it affected your
social interactions
i mean we haven't really been
socializing
like we used to but if you go to a
cocktail party for example do you find
that you're um
more connected to people do you find
that you you're more present yes yes i'm
not infallible here it's very
if with not with an insufficient amount
of sleep or the you know and not
something stressful going on in my life
i can i mean i had an interaction
earlier today where somebody in my house
was trying to talk to me
and i wasn't i was kind of beating
myself up afterwards for i wasn't really
in the mood and i wasn't as friendly as
i should have been and so your kid
it wasn't my kid it was a guest guest um
uh but i but yeah i'm sure there are
times when my kids trying to get my
attention and i'm on the phone you know
and
um so i am not infallible but more often
than i used to i'm able to sort of wake
back up
and get interested in the person i'm
talking to
actually listen to what they have to say
uh turn down the volume on the
me center dialogue and turn up the
interest in
what's happening
[Music]
hey life is short listeners wonderings
even the rich podcast is doing a
two-part series on the bizarre and
fascinating kidnapping of paddy hurst
and you won't want to miss it
one night in 1974 19 year old college
student patty hearst who happened to be
the heir to the hearst newspaper fortune
was kidnapped from her berkeley
apartment she was kept in a closet for
weeks while her captors made their
demands then after two months in
captivity and a completely unexpected
twist patty announced that her name was
tanya and was seen on video robbing a
bank with her captors the new season of
even the rich explores different
theories about what actually happened to
patty was she brainwashed or was she the
victim of stockholm syndrome listen to
even the rich on apple podcasts amazon
music or you can listen one week early
and add free by joining wondering plus
in the wondery app hey life assured
listeners business wars is a podcast
from wondering that brings you the full
stories behind some of the biggest
business battles in history in their new
season you'll hear about the fight
between espn vs fox sports to dominate
the sports television industry espn is
the american cable network that plays
the trail for around the clock sports
coverage athletes even change the way
they play just to get on sportscenter's
nightly highlight reels but right around
the corner rupert murdoch's fox sports
channel started gaining on espn in the
us the sports tv business is worth more
than 12 billion dollars the question is
who will come out on top fox sports or
espn listen to business wars espn versus
fox sports on apple podcast amazon music
or you can listen one week early and add
free by joining wondering plus in the
wundry app
hello hello
[Music]
i have a quick lightning round if you
don't mind indulging me okay
um so you know
clear your head don't think um
the opposite of what we were saying uh
what is your most commonly used emoji
i don't use emojis
great never never use one
very rarely maybe the thumbs up one okay
is that that's not that's not i use that
like i like something like somebody
texts me something okay yes i'll do it i
give it a like but i don't put it in the
feed
okay all right is that do you do that um
is that deliberately you don't you
you have uh are you against emojis i'm
old man emoji's kid emojis are a recent
i'm i'm a little i know
i am too i mean i'm 43 years old but i
find them really useful in like uh
establishing a tone sometimes like if i
say something that if i text something
that might be taken out of context that
you know i'll add like a wink or
something like just so you know i'm
joking something like that
uh anyway i don't want to sell you on
emojis no no no
it's okay it's okay i mean if you want
to be superficial like that it's your
choice
you know they have this one that might
be nice for you prayerheads
yes
uh if you could be a professional
athlete what sport would you play
basketball
okay uh nick's are you a knicks fan i i
hate sports um but it was the first
thing that came to my mind and i would
love to be tall
okay uh like skeelo
um
if uh i wish i were a little bit taller
oh yes yes yes um if if you
could have one snack food for the rest
of your life
what would it be
your
oreos
great they have all different kinds now
i'm seeing there's have you noticed this
yes but i like the the the originals
they're um vegan and um delicious and uh
are they they i once ate so many that i
woke up in the middle of the night and
puked
because you said that proudly yeah
no no not proudly but uh what is what is
is this so be gross but what is oreo
puke is it just does it look like what i
think it looks a little bit like
gunpowder
yeah
um wow you might have just turned me off
oreos that's quite a feat uh
what is your what was the movie that you
were really excited to introduce your
your kids to that you like couldn't wait
to show your kids star wars
oh yeah yeah are you what is your do you
have an order for the first three no
they go in order for me like i think
really the first one i mean i think the
second one is the uh this the empire
strikes back which was the second to be
released yeah it's episode five is the
best but i still would want to start
with it number the first one episode
four
yeah um and you must remember watching
those in the theater
i do when i was seven the first one came
out and my parents used to just drop us
off even if it was in the middle of the
movie it just let us start from the
middle and watch it uh as many times as
we wanted because i
loved it so much oh god that's cool yeah
but the first movies i saw in the
theater was empire strikes back so it
had
that to this day is
it's my favorite just because it was my
first
movie going experience you know and i
was so young to be i think i was too
young to be watching
uh because it's dark there's some really
like dark this might explain a lot of
your current problems
i know
thanks dad um
wha what is your
what is your go-to karaoke song if if
you sing karaoke it's the same as my
favorite emoji okay
okay i didn't know there was a song
called thumbs up
um or poop
yeah i i would if i had to go back i
would pick poop because i really do like
emoji um right yeah fun uh i don't
i don't think i've ever
really
been to i've been around karaoke but i
don't think i've i'm really making my
sound like myself sound like a terrible
person but i have not really ever done
karaoke i love music but i have never
done characters no you're making these
questions sound like they're really like
kind of lame cheesy questions um you're
making me second-guess this whole
aspect of the podcast uh
who was your first uh celebrity crush
dan
dan is thinking he is
uh
he's searching his my favorite celebrity
crushes were really
um rock stars but they were men so yeah
yeah okay oh yeah anybody uh oh i know
the answer uh lindsey buckingham and
stevie nicks from fleetwood mac oh yeah
of course god i ain't going back is a
song that i've just been on regular
rotation um i i love that song
your rumors you would say i mean don't
stop thinking about tomorrow
yeah what's your favorite what's your
go-to if you what's my favorite there's
a song i believe is the first song
on
tusk which is their under heralded oh
yeah experimental double album called
think about me and um it is i believe no
is that the name of this is that the
name of the song i forgot the name of
the song i'm embarrassed by that it is
my go-to song and it's the first song on
tusk and it has this incredibly
ineffably beautiful guitar part at the
end and my son and i
listen to it pretty regularly oh cool
how old's your son he's six and his uh i
gave him a
musical education part excellence when
he was a kid i was like
he could name
which beetle was singing when i played
him
yes
he's he's gotten into alexa
oh no and he's just kind of listening to
you know like
some dj named marshmallow all the time
and so like that's that's my life man oh
man that must be so disappointing i i i
wonder that about having kids now
because i would love to have kids but i
think like god forbid they god forbid i
show them one of those like star wars or
some music that i loved as a kid and
they're like ah
i don't get or
or they start listening to marshmallow
but what can you do you gotta just um
you can't yeah they're gonna do
and we were it was evening like golden
hour in maine and we were on the dock
beautiful and we were hurling ourselves
off the dock just me and him in this
freezing water and i had this whole
dialogue in my head about like what a
great dad i am doing this
thing with this kid and after like 45
minutes of that we got out i tell them
off we're walking back to our friend's
house it was beautiful i could hear the
crickets and i paused and i leaned over
and i was like alexander
i love you and he looked at me and said
who cares
[Laughter]
funny
he's funny you got to be proud of that
also in the scheme of things maybe it
was like some buddhist message in the
scheme of things you shouldn't hold on
to that yes i think that's right i had
expectations that it was going to be
some big moment and myself yes the great
teacher uh
yeah i had my head up my ass right that
that he was going to look back at you
and say he loves you and the strings
music was going to swell um
but that is that's really funny uh if
you
if you had to get a tattoo uh what would
you get and and where i've been thinking
about this recently because my wife and
i are thinking about getting tattoos
like sort of here i'm sure you can't see
this
on the wrist
under belly of the forearm um
i
what i want to get is there's a very uh
it's a venerable
buddhist expression or sort of a wish
that you can foster
which is that may your actions be to the
benefit of all beings so for the benefit
of all beings is the expression and it's
not really my style because i like to
have like a wink
in everything i doing or like some
little bit of sarcasm but i truly do try
to develop that motivation especially
since i'm aware of how
selfish i really can be and i love what
i love about buddhism what i love about
meditation is you can counter program
against some of your darker instincts
and i want to develop
that motivation more and more that is
great i thought about putting f t
b o b o
on my wrist as a thing to bring me back
to like
what i should be operating out of well
well dan this is a perfect opportunity
to marry that with uh an emoji because
you could do for the benefit of all
beings and then a winky face just to get
the wink in there
what am i going to kind of
or the poop whatever whatever you want
however you want to color it
um
i think that's really cool there's one
that i want to get i don't have any
tattoos but um
uh i i got one
the lead the singer of green day i got
drunk with green day once and really
that's awesome yeah that's the only cool
part of the story uh
so i should just i should just end it
there i got drunk with green day um and
he
i was so drunk and he couldn't believe
it he was so incredulous that i didn't
have tattoos and he had his security guy
give him a needle i don't know where he
got i'm such a germaphobe and i was so
drunk that i didn't even see where it
came from i and he split out he just
cracked open a pen in this hotel room
and he started stick and poke like
prison style tattooing a heart on my
ankle and so for years i had this heart
uh
on my ankles i told you the story just
got so much less cool no this is
actually a good story i'm with you so
what happened to the heart is it still
well if no it faded i mean there's still
indentations in my skin but it faded
after a couple years my friend said it
looked like ringworm at the time
and it wasn't totally connected it
started to look really weird but uh it's
it's technically
i guess if there's no ink left it
doesn't count as a tattoo um
but i uh
my
kate uh who introduced me to you and i
were doing this movie and
and the first ad said um he was this
really
eloquent british guy i loved him he was
um
just really sweet and articulate and he
said
all right we're going to he gave a
little speech before one day of shooting
he said all right then let's commit it
to history
and i just thought that was such a
wonderful idea committed to history
so i think if i got one it would be that
uh maybe it's somewhere small um it's
been and it was such a great experience
such a transformative experience that i
i do want to commit it to history
maybe maybe the guy from green day is
available
yeah and his uh his security guy um
billy joe i should get him on the show
talk to him um
uh what is your favorite fruit dan
bananas
okay
that was easy
it was an easy one um
such a useful fruit too you don't have
to wash it i love them uh you can eat
them
part i because i travel to all sorts of
difficult parts of the world you can eat
bananas anywhere for that very reason
yes that's true
yeah they have their own little
packaging yes um
who would you want to play you in your
biopic
the dan harris i actually had a very
strange experience recently where there
have been several attempts to
option 10 happier and i've usually said
no
until now
but i uh so i did say yes to it didn't
end up happening but i did say yes
uh to
uh
to one company and it didn't end up
happening but it would have been this
guy named i didn't choose this actor but
i really didn't like him a lot
personally was this guy named hugh dancy
oh yes who is way better looking than i
am so i was told that's not true
that he he looks like hugh he does look
like you uh he was such a tough name
must be such a tough name to live with
with all the hey hugh
uh that great curvier enthusiasm where
he's like [ __ ] you
[Laughter]
um yeah you guys do look alike
for sure i could see that um
who is your favorite muppet i'm sure you
guys are watching the drummer
oh yeah yeah sure
uh could probably use some meditation or
or not maybe he's just
totally at peace
i mean he might be i mean i am a drummer
and by the way just a little quick
watching recommendation i just there's
an amazing new documentary on netflix
called count me in it's all about
drummers and i have been playing drums
since i was 10 and it's an awesome
documentary and i really showed it to my
son because he wants to learn how to
play drums and animal
really
has done something that i have no i have
rarely succeeded in doing which is
dropping the self-consciousness dropping
the
what other people think of you and just
going for it
yes that's true that's true that i've
always struggled with that as well
um
what is your what's your go-to pizza top
and you mentioned that pizza is still
something that you indulge in we moved
up to the suburbs and there's this local
pizza place that makes vodka sauce pizza
huh so instead of tomato sauce it's like
you know penne i love vodka yeah yeah
sauce on the pizza
oh wow really good do you prefer dogs or
cats cats we have four
four yeah we just got a fourth uh my
wife came home with a kitten the other
day
oh but did she find it
she was at the vet with one of the other
cats because basically we're at the vet
24 7 and there was a little kitten in
the waiting room and
she made me come with her immediately go
back to go back to see the kitten i said
let's give it an evening and uh that
night she
submitted the before sleeping on it
she which was what i had requested she
submitted the application and the next
morning we had been accepted and now we
have this cat
so you had to do a slightly longer
meditation
actually you know what i love animals i
would have dogs too and now that we live
in the suburbs i would i'm the door is
open i am a huge animal fan do you
prefer that this i'm really curious
about the beetles or the stones beetles
but i love them
but yes that's but but if you had to
hear you're at a bar
you have like three songs you can put on
the jukebox they have to beat all the
beatles songs what do you want to hear
dear prudence
ah i was just listening to i love dear
prudence
maybe hey jude which i wouldn't have
picked before but my son loves it so
much that i i've really started to warm
to it i heard a great story about dear
prudence which was uh
it was about the maharashtrians when
they were studying with them do you know
this yeah this story yeah
yeah it's amazing yes yes and it was i
love that they were just like come
outside we want to like we want to [ __ ]
like we all wanted to just touch her
and then that song like that is just
about and that that's what they were
concerned with when they were at this
spiritual retreat they were just all
trying to like hook up
it's kind of amazing and apparently
that's what sexy sadie is about sexy
sadie was i didn't know that yes it was
their [ __ ] you to the mauricio yeah yes
yes what have you done you made a fool
of amazing um this has truly been such a
pleasure and again like i don't want to
labor the point but i am
such a fan of what you're doing and it's
been such an instrumental part in my uh
of my life so
huge thanks thank you for saying that i
really appreciate it i really appreciate
it means a lot and uh let's keep it
going let's keep it going okay and uh
we'll begin again
[Music]
so that's so that so that happened so
that happened god i you know i haven't
heard it in a little bit but it's just
it's it's one of the most neutral voices
you could hear yeah no it's kind of more
no it's not it's newsy
well it's it's a little bit more like
this it's it's newsy but very
honest he's very authentic you wanted it
to be
bostonian yes uh it no it wasn't at all
no well he's he talks about that in this
book that he worked that out he like got
rid of that
he's from newton yeah
mass yeah um
yeah as well as is the girl you lost
your virginity oh did i say that sure
did that's how you started the interview
you know what's crazy i said that at a
dinner party the other day whenever
newton massachusetts why are you touting
this thing i i don't know and my it's
almost like you're proud that you've had
sex
maybe you are subconsciously
it's like something right
no why
cool i'm 43. it's weird to say oh i i
lost my virginity to this girl when you
say a girl and you're 43. i know you
were a boy when it happened but she was
a there's something weird about saying
that
hearing that you know that's true to
this girl as a middle-aged man yeah i
guess so
i know but you know it was nice i like
it was a good person to have that
experience with i like i'll always
really appreciate the way she did
because obviously if she was gentle yeah
and like and taught me stuff it was like
a good teacher how much older was she
she was four years older oh my god i
almost thought you said 40.
she was 40 years 40. she was 65. uh you
know we should talk about the guest dan
yes i know i know i might be reading too
much into it knowing what i know about
him
um not knowing that much about him but
knowing what he does for a living
he strikes me as the kind of person who
is
like uh a type a person who's chill
yes and he seems like someone who
meditates to me you know isn't he yeah
he seems very present and i know man and
patient yes part of that is like
professionally he's good at that he's
good at
interviews is that your stomach yeah
it's the falafel i just ate because it's
you know it's true
yeah that'll do it protein and it's not
a good thing to have right before you
record i know i shouldn't have done that
i was
but um yeah he yeah but not all of
people in his position are as present
and like connected i i've done a this is
some humble brag i've done those shows
though like you know we've done them for
like later than matter and
you see there's a real uh degree there's
a gradation congratulations for sure of
like how present connected somebody is
in an interview and i would argue that
he is i think mo i think most of them
are
they're not all that like they're not
great listeners all the time also on
those morning shows they have things in
their ear people are talking to them
it's really hard to like stay focused
and he's just so impressive he's just
such an impressive speaker and he seems
so like i love how honesty is about i
mean i love we talk about that a lot on
the show but like he really especially
in the book he gets into what i talk
about warts and all right and that was a
that's a really like difficult thing to
overcome i think he felt a lot of shame
from that
from that moment yeah and he's used i
mean what a great example of like
turning lemons into lemonade
a colloquialism that he probably
wouldn't use he'd be he'd find something
a lot smarter how much of that panic
attack was
and you might not be able to answer this
but i was curious when he was talking
about it how much of it
was
drug induced
versus uh trauma induced from his
experiences overseas or or do you think
he couldn't say i was it like the night
before did he when he told the story was
it the night before he had a great
question he you know cocaine for 14
hours and it was like
spinning out hmm well i think it's you
know the so maybe it was more of a
physical thing than anything else
maybe i think it is most i think it
starts it's triggered by something
physical like the the only thing i can
really relate it to is um where i came
closest to that in a professional way
was
when i
was on stage and i was hungover
i had been drinking and stuff the night
before but it was an evening show so i
had the whole day to recover and there
was just a and i took this thing
somebody gave me a pill that was like oh
take this it'll help with hangovers and
and it made my stomach weird and that
then triggered
severe anxiety like an anxiety response
in my head which was this which was oh
my god you're on stage like i couldn't
get off stage i was nauseous i was going
to throw up
and so that's what the anxiety became
he talks about this in a lot is the
stories that you tell you so you tell
yourself a story and the story i was
telling myself was that i was going to
throw up and embarrass myself on a
that's right broadway stage
and um
that was of course i and i didn't uh
but that's what you start spinning out
about that's what like oh because the
stakes are high yeah they were high for
him
and sawyer regular like oh my god
charles gibson like i can't imagine
would have been scarier if it was peter
jennings yes that was another revelation
about the book was and my talk with him
today how
intimidating he was but it makes sense
doesn't it uh kind of what surprised me
though was his temper because my
association not so even not temper but
like
his yeah his temper yeah his temper and
kind of like hostility kind of
snarkiness yes i know i don't know what
what what word do you use but um
yeah he wouldn't say that to his face
sure wouldn't my association with peter
jennings
is so pure you know because we were kids
right and he was he was the news anchor
he was like our walter croc yes okay
when i think of him it's i think like so
stable oh stable and even keel
and
authoritative yeah yeah and not at all i
can't imagine that version of him in my
in my brain no being like oh you're
gonna wear that i
know like nice suit loser
i can't it's like i can't even imagine
trying to imagine rick moranis or like
john candy being like unfunny yeah you
know it's like or a jerk or a jerk yeah
exactly it's it's so hard to imagine or
both an unfunny jerk
um yeah you're right he's so sorry you
don't both have to think of peter
jennings as a pillar of stability and
authoritative
decisiveness um he he was like that he
was the guy that you trusted completely
and and like would never like fly off
the handle i can't imagine and there was
there were he had competition back in
the day you know there was tom brokaw
stan rather dan rather ted koppel diane
sawyer yeah yeah there were his
competition but i always liked peter
jennings the best you know bothered to
delay peter jennings the best out of all
those authoritative news anchors um you
don't have to watch peter jennings
because your father watched him and
liked him
he was also
i don't know how to say this this must
speak to
some some of my brain being somewhere on
the kinsey scale he was also like the
most handsome here we go again oh
boy okay okay
um yeah i right i mean is that part of
it was he the most handsome
ted koppel i mean yeah tom brokaw was
pretty handsome he was i you know i i
might go
actually i might put tom brokaw ahead
but he yeah chuck [ __ ] mary with uh
the iconic news anchors from the 80s and
90s
who would you do who would you uh i
would
i
probably not including dinosaur let's
say it's all men it'll make it easier no
much easier much easier for you
oh well who cares time's changing yeah
it's cool
stop stop trying to
out myself co-opt the bisexual movement
geez i hope people don't think i am but
why
what's wrong with that what would be
wrong with that man
oh no
it's hard to get out yeah um anyway i
wonder if dan harris ever encounters
that i would like to try his app i sent
it to you no i don't don't yell at me
that's not the way to encourage
meditation by the way it's not yeah
that's true it's not a good example of
how meditations helped me because as he
was talking about it i
i realized pretty firmly that oh this is
this is right up my alley yeah
like in a lot of ways because i think
oh gross
that went right out of my alley and this
is a small room you know i know well
because a lot of the things he was
talking about about like
uh your brain going and thinking about
all these other things i i think i've
just gotten used to doing that in my
life and that's become normal in my
brain because i i think that i have like
a very consistent undercurrent of
anxiety yeah in my life yeah that i've
just gotten very used to yeah you think
well then like it's normal right but
yeah when you hear someone talk about
that and it sounds like something you do
you realize that
just because you've gotten used to
something doesn't make it normal and it
doesn't mean there's not a way to combat
it i am so excited for you because that
is the exact type of mindset that you
need to get into this it's a way to help
you understand your reactivity how to
not be reactive to what's that supposed
to mean
like well what i just did with you
but like when you get a text for example
that let's say it's from a parent who
might say something that is kind of
triggering it teaches you just put it
down put it down set it aside the phone
or the whole
the whole and process sit with the uncom
sit with how you feel about it it
doesn't tell you not to feel i was
curious about
why he left
his position at abc news to focus on the
meditation app beyond the obvious which
is
money yeah well no that it was doing
well and he was and he's passionate
about it
um
but i wondered
what led to that full-time shift and i
wonder if he misses
being a news man and if he harbors any
desire to go back to it at some point
yeah that those would be great questions
for him oh you know i can um
we should have done the interview i'm
just curious you know what i this is
because that's a pretty big job
especially for a guy who clearly is and
talks about being very ambitious and
driven i know but you know just to give
up you know decades of experience not to
defend my not asking him that but i
think i just assumed it was because he
was so um
he i i he was he was so uh
consumed with it and it's it's the kind
of thing where i think you
it does become your entire life and the
hours are crazy and you know he's got a
family and stuff um
and and i think he probably saw the
negative effects that it was having on
him you know all of that
all of that anxiety and stuff well i
guess we don't have to ask him you know
that's good i guess this will never
really get true but that's my theory
um it's fine
i thought you did an excellent job with
the interview but at one point when he
was explaining the idea of
starting over in his own meditation
you interrupted him like 12 times
so god it was really funny
that's funny
that's funny oh no let's read a letter
oh wow really yeah efficient okay geez
wow
all right trying not to crinkle it as
much
that was you trying not to cringe well
not at the first part was i forgot about
it and then as i
became more conscious of it
here we go from cheyenne patrick subject
peace shivers oh i like it already
also cheyenne's a cool name hi
three exclamation points christian and
justin
one exclamation mark point point
my name is cheyenne i'm from portland
oregon i love when you guys talk about
your love for portland maybe one day we
will run into each other i love portland
long time listener first time caller i
just finished watching ted lasso and
loved that line i had to use it
i guess that's a line in ted long time
listen
either
first of all you guys are so funny thank
you cheyenne i love your brother chatter
i also enjoyed the episode of your
grandma and love love when you two talk
about her no you guys have the coolest
job but we do and what a cool job it is
a really fun we love that's our favorite
episode too i just finished the david
copperfield episode and had to tell you
my pea shiver story great i was on a
road trip with my one-year-old daughter
just the two of us and i had to pee i
still had an hour to go on the trip so i
needed to stop and i would also have to
wake her up and take her into the
bathroom with me while trying to pee
anyways while i was peeing amelia my
daughter great name also started to pee
which every time a baby pees they
usually shiver huh i don't know that
but at the same time not know that
babies shiver when they pee
but
but at the same time the piece started
coming out of her diaper and onto my leg
luckily i just that doesn't gross me out
at all
not baby people yeah
even people pee i mean unless it was
like
some people yeah that's true ugh like a
dehydrated like strange repeat yeah
awful yeah like six cups of coffee yeah
okay
and like asparagus
luckily i had a change of clothes in the
car but such terrible timing this is
such a gross story i can't believe i'm
emailing you guys this but anyways long
story short
christian babies pee shiver on the rag
it's good to know yeah it is good to
know and we were speculating about women
that's right piss shivering peace of
mind that's right babies do it
interesting um it's really good to know
uh and well i relate to that too because
i i don't do it on the reg
like i don't either i only do it when
yeah you know trip not necessarily a
long trip but i've been holding it in
for a while yeah
anyways on the topic of babies as a
first-time parent it's fun to hear would
would you rather with a parenting theme
so here's mine
would you rather take a baby on an
eight-hour plane flight where he or she
screams the whole flight oh man that's
i i know i'm not looking forward to that
that's a
that's gonna be something i have to use
meditation for really that's gonna come
in handy well you don't have a baby so
you don't have to really worry about it
at the moment but i'm saying like
hypothetically um okay either that eight
hour flight where she's screaming boy or
where he or she is quiet but poops and
spits up every hour of the flight
um
definitely be second one yeah yeah for
sure especially because from my
experience of baby poop it's not bad
yeah and and spit up's not bad yeah i
mean it's not great
but it's not like it'll
you know uh
infect the whole
plane so it's not like other people are
gonna be mad at you that's true even
though they shouldn't be mad at you if
the baby's crying but i think i know my
personality enough to know that
i would feel
bad
guilty and bad if my baby if my
hypothetical baby was making a lot of
noise disrupting people it'd be constant
they would be [ __ ] to get mad at me
i know but i would still feel bad i
think i would too um yeah definitely be
um good hypothetical i i think for me it
would just be a constant source of
anxiety as well
they're screaming yeah and like and i
know you get used to it and all that and
i'm sure by that point i will have
gotten used to it a little bit more
a baby screaming in public and you know
it's like what can you do oof i don't
know but i always get annoyed when and i
think that when even with my meditation
i think i had that recently a baby was
crying on the whole flight it was it was
about an eight-hour flight it was um
across the atlantic and so
man i don't know i i love
our nephews and i love meeting like my
friends kids and stuff but when i'm in
the grocery store in any sort of public
place and
and i see kids who are carrying on and i
look at their parents and they seem like
at their wits i know
i always
have this feeling of oof
kind of glad i'm not doing that right
now i know i know i mean obviously there
are so many good things about it i don't
mean to parent shame but i'm just being
honest that seems really unappealing to
me well um your honesty is really
appreciated good and and we don't have
any frame of reference no no the other
side we don't know the beauty of it in
the church i'm sure if you have your own
kid
you get so much
joy from this that all the bad stuff
seems worth it um so i can only imagine
yeah and i'm sure cheyenne can attest to
that and dan harris can too because he
has his little child i think he has one
child one child you kept saying kids
plural he didn't correct you huh but he
i believe he has one boy he's probably
really good at like discerning what
needs to be corrected
um anyway i hope to get there one day
you will yeah
it's a learning process that's the nice
thing about the show and
life in general and and beginning again
amen uh so thank you cheyenne and if you
guys would like to write in our email
address is life is short at wundery.com
so thanks to cheyenne and to dan harris
i can't wait to if you're listening i
can't wait to read
your book and uh
download your app and yeah you should 10
yeah 10 check it out and um and we will
talk to you soon
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
life is short is hosted by me justin
long it is co-hosted by you christian
law also a producer another producer is
megan v monaco and katy
allen senior producer is michelle miesh
lance and the audio engineer is sergio
enriquez the executive producer is
marshall louis and all of it is for a
company that is called
wandering
[Music]
you mean um
there are a lot of rabbits around
what a lot of rabbits
yeah do you did you see the rabbits
today no
by the garden
yeah
what does that mean oh yeah
oh yeah what is have you heard the word
slap the term slaps
that slabs
[Music]
it means something's really oh it's
really good it's going to say
that
slaps something to splash
yeah it's always changing slacks
no i'm sure you had a word now you use
it your parents ain't used
like this that's
yeah your parents probably would have
been like boss why not just say that's
good
you know boss or red yeah rad that was
more 80s i thought
[Music]
supportive
you